let's say that i've just won some type
of contest at a car dealership and
they're going to give me a brand new car
and in deciding which car they give me
they're first going to randomly select
the engine type so the engine will come
in
two different varieties it'll either be
a four cylinder
four cylinder engine
or a six cylinder engine and they're
literally just gonna flip a fair coin to
decide whether i get a four cylinder
engine or a six cylinder engine then
they're going to pick the color and
there's four different colors that the
cars come in so i'll write color in a
neutral color so you could get a red car
that's not red
let me do that in an actual red color
closer to red you could get a red car
you could get a blue car
blue car you could get a green car
you could get a green car
or you could get a white car
or you could get a white car and once
again they're going to randomly let's
say just pick they're going to have red
blue green and white and little slips of
paper in a bowl and they're just going
to pick one of them out so all of these
are equally likely
so given this that they're just going to
flip a coin to pick the engine and
they're also going to that all of these
the color is all equally likely i want
to think about the probability of
getting a six-cylinder white car
the probability of getting a
six-cylinder wide car
so i encourage you to pause the video
and think about it on your own
well one way to think about this is what
are all of the equally likely possible
outcomes and then which of those match
six cylinder white car
well first we could think about the
engine decision we're either going to
get a four cylinder engine
so the first decision is the engine you
could view it that way you're gonna get
a four-cylinder engine or you're going
to get a six-cylinder engine
now if you've got a four-cylinder engine
you're either going to get
red
blue
green
or white
or
white
and if you've got a six cylinder engine
once again you're either going to get
red
blue
i think you see where this is going
that's not blue
red
blue
green
or white
or
white
so how many possible outcomes are there
well you could just count the you could
kind of say the leaves of this tree
diagram one two three four five six
seven eight possible outcomes and that
makes sense you have two possible
engines times four possible colors two
times four and you see that right here
one group of four two groups of four so
this outcome right here is a four
cylinder blue car
and this outcome over here is a six
cylinder green car so there's eight
equally possible outcomes and which
outcome matches the one that we i guess
are hoping for the white six cylinder
car well that's this one right over here
it's one of eight equally likely events
so we have a 1 8 probability now this
wasn't the only way that we could have
drawn the t diagram we could have
thought about color as the first row of
this tree so we could have said look
we're either going to get a let me do it
down here so i have a little more space
we're either going to get a
red
a blue
a that's not blue changing colors is the
hard part
a blue
a green
man
make it
a green
or a white car
and then for each of those colors i'm
either going to get a four cylinder or
six cylinder engine so it's either going
to be four
or six
either going to be four
either gonna be four
or six
either going to be four or six this
would be another way of drawing a t
drive a t a tree diagram to represent
all of the outcomes so what is this
outcome right over here this is a six
cylinder red car this is a four cylinder
blue car right over here which is the
one that we care about a white
six-cylinder car that's this outcome
right over here once again you see you
have eight equally likely outcomes and
that happens because you have four
possible colors and then for each of
those four possible colors you have two
different engine types